[Applause]
[Music]
i think someone took the wrong turn and
that's why the car suddenly swerved so
hard and you see me literally go
sideways like that that was not
choreographed that was an accident
tomorrow never dies
i will never forget when i was playing
weilin
someone said to me just enjoy it you're
in a bond movie you don't have to take
it so seriously which in a sense is true
because there's so many things going on
but then we all also knew you have to
take it seriously because of your
character you're not convinced with your
character you can't deliver the
sincerity of a character nobody will
believe what you are playing or what you
are trying to tell them
the producers who understand how
important the legacy of bond is to the
audiences around the world and how to
maintain and expand because it was
always very much the man's world right
all the guys love to be james bond and
the women were all almost always the
bond girls uh but they were ready at
that time when they came looking for me
was to have much more depth in emotions
and the quality of their
nature in the film
allow me
don't get any ideas mr bond maybe we go
after general chang together thanks for
washing my hair
i work alone i was very blessed that
that was the the train of thought going
through their minds when they were
writing tomorrow never dies i will never
forget my first experience meeting
barber broccoli one of the main
producers the most amazing strong
powerful woman i think because of her
that kind of character that strong woman
was pushed very much far forward in
the front
because of my background coming from
having done a lot of stunt work and
actual fighting and things like that
barbara and michael wilson were very
smart they said to me bring your sun
team it was a great experience for them
because it was a luxury too because
normally in hong kong
we don't have time
to
rehearse for us actors we get onset we
learn it and we shoot it so i remember
when my guys came barbara said to me
where's your son team and i'm i'm like i
went looking for them and they were all
in the green room i was going guys come
on what kind of example are you setting
you know they have they sent you the
mock-up of the set to hong kong like
weeks before you were supposed and now
that you get here you're all just
lounging they said well we have five
different ways which one do you want
because they've seen the sets in the
mock-up so they understood the layout so
when they actually came to the layout
they went okay we know exactly what
we're doing they said i'm waiting for
your director to come to show him the
five different setups so that's the
speed that they work barbara and michael
my producers were more comfortable
because they could see that we work
together and we know each other and they
would keep me safe but if not it would
have been very difficult for them to say
why is she on the second floor and
there's no harness you know
that was a great experience for both
sides to to see how the east works in
that way when we we don't have the that
kind of money or the kind of time you
know to to have long setups but we work
efficiently and very very quickly
crouching tiger hidden dragon
crouching jacket hidden dragon is poetry
in motion
[Music]
and it's angry his vision his passion
for martial arts which when i first met
him straight after
tomorrow never dies to talk about
crouching tiger all these martial arts
movies the kung fu movies as we call
them is something that we all grow up
with it's like our marvel comics and he
was so fascinated he wanted to try out
every single form of martial arts and
every
weapon there was i thought he was
kidding when i first walked into his
where he was prepping for all this the
research he was doing i seriously
thought he was kidding until when i
walked onto the set on the final fight
sequence and all the the the weapons
were there and he said i want you to use
all of them i'm like you're kidding
right
but he was not he never jokes around
with things like that
[Music]
we always say there is no
action without drama it goes hand in
hand you're talking about the emotional
feeling
[Applause]
the drama of the fighting is the story
and that is the storyteller telling you
this is the conflict between these two
women over the sword and that's very
symbolic of the man i think in any movie
as well even for tomorrow advertise when
you have the most incredible explosions
you know planes and motorcycles and
things like that the drama of it the
closeness of the two characters that
makes you believe the urgency the the
reason for why why they are doing that
police story three super cop
personally it was a very important movie
at that time because i had moved away
and retired from the film business for
about three four four years police story
three super cup was my first comeback so
it was important to remind my audiences
hey i'm still here and hey
i'm still you know what what you loved
before
[Music]
and then i was getting to work with
stanley tong the director who i met when
he was a stunt man and so he came to me
and said i have a jackie chan movie and
i want you to be part of it like his
counterpart okay it was like playing
with james bond opposite them as their
equal that was a very huge statement on
every level for me it was a great
privilege for the women it was like yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i will never be crazy enough to to do
those stunts again well we did have an
accident but i was fortunate i came out
of it not hurt we don't really rehearse
our
big scenes if you're going to do it you
might as well shoot it
right so let's not waste it so i get up
on the truck dodging the bullets rolling
off the van and i go off the van and
jackie pulls up in his little
convertible and i land on his bonnet i
crash the windscreen which saves my fall
and then i roll off his car and i go oh
that looks okay i can just you know roll
down and then you're standing up there
and you go like oh this feels a little
different way it's not staying still and
then his car is not staying still either
everything is moving and i remember in
my head i went well
i'm never gonna know until i tried right
so i took the roll
everything went wrong the windscreen did
not shatter the things that were
supposed to make it go
it didn't so jackie couldn't get a
handle on me when you look watch the
outtakes he scrambled over the
windscreen and tried to hold on to me
luckily he grabbed onto a bit of my
shirt as i was sliding off the car he
saved me i think my life but don't tell
him that and as i rolled off if he
didn't give me that little extra jerk i
could i would have landed on my head
first and that would have been the
disaster of my life you know the saying
when you fall off the horse you have to
get back right on
for me at that moment was like i know
what i didn't do right now i know the
feeling let's do it try and catch it
this time suddenly when she rejected
it's okay it's okay she said it's okay
get back in the car
so we turned around and we did it in the
next check that was crazy but you know
don't do
it so at that time i did take more risks
than usual like you know hanging on the
van
i think someone took the wrong turn and
that's why the car suddenly swerved so
so hard and you see me literally go
sideways like that that was not
choreographed that was an accident
[Music]
jackie was the one who had a bigger
problem he actually came up to me at one
stage and he says michelle are you
trying to kill me and i'm like no why
would i do that we're buddies right and
he goes no because i was doing this
crazy motorcycle stunt right when he saw
me do that son he was like oh no if you
do anything more than that where am i
going to come from that's why he did the
helicopter stunt it's not fair for me to
suddenly go
look at me
so we had to have a little bit of a
balance and i think we managed to to to
do that quite well at the end of the day
so that's why we're still great friends
crazy rich asians
from the book the the mother is just an
antagonist she was very more superficial
being able to work very closely with
john chu i had asked him at the
beginning what kind of movie are you
making what's the tone of your film is
it going to be like a hangover too which
is a very legitimate question because if
you read the book it very much reads
like that as well right it's fun it's
crazy it's out there if he said that i
would have said that would have been a
wasted opportunity to show in depth with
real emotions since their integrity what
this culture is and that was such a
great opportunity because we hadn't had
an all china asian cast i think since
joy luck club i wanted to be part of it
but i didn't want to be part of
something that i didn't believe in john
chu said to me if i did that my mother
would kill me
bang if you understand what your mother
thinks you have there's a lot of that in
you pursuing one's passion
how american
well your mother is very open-minded not
like here where parents are obsessed
with shaping the life of the children he
said i grew up with understanding the
hierarchy in family the feline piety
that we have to show to our elders how
to greet not just who to greet but how
to greet when we sit down for dinner who
starts to eat first and who you have to
address you know and greet so he
understood the cultural the real
cultural and not just a superficial you
know i don't want to know about my
history or culture where i come from
that gave me great confidence that he
would
understand why this mother
character was so important because
initially she only appears not that many
times in fact with her son only twice
some things
i need to figure out on my own
is that an american accent i'm hearing
how do i look
perfect but in those moments you have to
feel the love that strong bond and
connection if you don't then what is the
reason for for him to go back to to
singapore
right there must be something that will
always pull him back and that's love of
a family that's keeping a family
together for me that was a very very um
important role
you don't know me
i know you're not what nick needs the
mahjong scene a battle of wit without
the fists the tiles that sound the
clicky clack you know that tempo that
rhythm the women telling each other what
they feel and why they are going in that
direction it was beautiful but it was
powerful there were many days when i
wondered if i would ever measure up
but having been through it all
i know this much
you will never be enough everybody loved
the line when i said you will never be
enough
everybody's always very scared when i
say that and john you said you terrified
me
but i think what i loved most about was
the reaction to that character i had
young people come up to me and say i
understand my mom better now or i
understand my mother-in-law better now i
can go back and have a conversation with
my mom now and i think that was very
important when i approach it's like i
have to know the character where is she
really coming from she was dutiful she
was loyal she was fiercely devoted to
her family but most of all that was love
that was real love the general mother's
role
to nurture to protect but then the most
important is to let go and i approach it
like that knowing these are the feelings
that a mother would have so that when i
am there as eleanor young i am a mother
i am just simply a mother who loves her
son
everything everywhere all at once
i always try not to inject me
into the character
because i see the character as a real
person who needs to have real emotions
uh a path what i saw in evelyn was a
very hard-working immigrant he's trying
so hard to be keeping her family
together to be a success in her her
father's eyes to prove that she's a good
daughter
and i see evelyn
in so many people around me i felt that
a need to tell their story but in a very
um
not the usual way because the daniels
presented it in such a psychedelic crazy
insane contemporary way sometimes in
science fiction that's where you can
really go to the stars and across the
universes like we have done and still be
credible and believable because this is
the universe that we have created i
think that was the challenge and it it
kept me as the actor grounded because
i felt this character and because every
day when i go on to the set i was like
okay sometimes i have no idea we are
jumping from one universe to the other
one the chaos at that moment of filming
is also what the character was going
evelyn was going through evelyn
was confused was
fractured she was trying to come to
terms with what was happening with her
it was like taking a look at your own
life and going like am i
a failure am i this am i that could i
have done better
maybe that is one thing that i do put in
taking from my experiences because it is
very personal not every decision that
you make is going to be the perfect one
and that's when mistakes hopefully makes
you wiser
and smarter and don't do it again
and if you do it again that means you're
really dumb
for me this whole journey was about
evelyn
the character who understood she will
never give up that also reflects on me
as a person
because i refuse to give up i think when
you give up or give in you've already
lost whatever it is it's the character
and if you find that character and you
connect you're almost living
vicariously through that character
that's when you really
love what you're watching or feeling in
everything everywhere all at once my god
i think it has to start from the moment
i got the script fortunately i was
coming to l.a met with the daniels had
to meet with the daniels because i would
only take on a project if there is real
passion if when i speak to them i see
the passion in their eyes i hear it in
coming from here because i'm not gonna
go and leave my family and people i love
for three four months at a time on lip
service on doing something that even you
don't believe in how are you going to
convince me to be part of that so when i
met them i didn't tell them
because when i read the script i thought
this is something oh dear
no this is something i've been waiting
for
for a long time
that's going to
give me the opportunity
to show
my fans
my family my audience
what i'm capable of
to be funny
to be real
to be
sad
finally somebody understood that i can
do all these things